c'est normal
que le président prenne la parole
pour donner la ligne pour dire ce qu'il
pense de la situation quelles sont ses
orientations et ses choix en même temps
la pandémie c'était peu de choses dans
son discours c'était un discours de
candidat ce que c'était un discours de
candidat et c'est pas nouveau ça fait
des mois que le président sillonne la
france pour distribuer des milliards
pour distribuer des millions et en somme
pour faire campagne et hier soir une
fois encore il a fait campagne en
annonçant des mesures
unilatérales que personne ne connaissait
qui ont été discutés nulle part alors
précisément sur le fond la réforme des
retraites qui est abandonnée ça restera
comme le grand regret de ce quinquennat
selon vos goûters celui là comme
d'autres beaucoup de regret je crois
surtout que tout le monde attend la
parole présidentielle
comme un messie qui parle et qui
distribue
la bonne parole je crois que l'atome
en 2010 huit ans nous annoncer la
fermeture des ep r aujourd'hui on nous
annonce des investissements pour en
créer aucun débat même même la fameuse
convention citoyenne et balayer tout ça
sort de l'elysée sans aucune préparation
des concertations et on fait la même
chose pour la justice avec une
convention pour la justice à 6,8 je
crois que on peut pas continuer à voir
un pays
avec un président qui décide de tout et
un parlement qui n'existe plus